you might think they're very different
from each other the Big Bang is very
very dense very very hot the remote
future will be very very rarified and
very very cold
[Music]
you've suggested that you know perhaps
the Big Bang wasn't in fact the
beginning uh you've famous for a view
called conformal selectrical cosmology I
wondered if you could tell us a bit
about this yes well you see that was
where I finally went it took me a long
time you see I'd spent the ages trying
to make
sense of bringing quantum mechanics
explaining the singularities that way
and I made a sort of just a
assumption about singularities in the
past with no justification from physics
just
what I used to call the vile curvature
hypothesis
vile curvature is a particular kind of
curvature which describes gravitational
field getting very strong rather than
the matter getting very strong
and so I just said okay singularities in
the past have got some zero vial
curvature just the hypothesis
can't do much with that but one of my
graduate students Paul Todd he's had a
much better way of saying it he said why
don't you say
that you can stretch out the Big Bang
this is a kind of trick I'd used quite a
lot what's called conformal big and
small
could stretch out the big bang and it
can make it nice and smooth he says why
did you say it like that and said that
it's if you stretch the big bang out
then you you can make it smooth that's
basically his Criterion that's a much
better way of saying it so I picked up
on that I said well why is it so smooth
yes well you see the big bang is in a
certain sense not singular at all
it's really completely different from
the singularities in the future why is
it not singular at all well it's not
singular if you use a kind of geometry
which is called conformal geometry
now conformal geometry is the geometry
of angles if you like so or shapes small
shapes
it doesn't you forget distances so big
and small are equivalent the different
shapes are an equivalent it's a very
useful
image to have are these pictures due to
the Dutch artist M.C Escher yes where he
Illustrated
particular type of geometry it's called
um
hyperbolic geometry don't worry too much
about that but in these pictures they're
called Circle limits and you the most
famous ones with angels and devils and
you can see the angels and devils in the
middle and as you get towards the edge
you can still see the shapes of them are
pretty well the same but they're much
much smaller and you can see right up to
the edge
I mean I've looked at these pictures of
Ash I've been seeing some of the
originals they're absolutely amazing you
can look right up the edge and he's
actually
made them very very precise yeah to the
edge so the picture is that the Universe
this is not just for the big bang no I
don't think we're around just for
Infinity the remote future can be
squashed down to make it a boundary yes
and I used to use this trick
been studying
gravitational radiation gravitational
waves in order to study them nicely and
to see how much energy they carry and
things like that it's useful to squash
down infinity and then you can see
you've got a nice boundary at the edge
and you can do your calculations rather
than taking horrible limits and things
which is not very good at doing but
looking at the geometry yes of the
squash down Infinity yes so you can
squash down infinity and now that we
have this thing people misleadingly
refer to as dark energy
it's really Einstein's cosmological
constant which he introduced for the
wrong reason just after he introduced
his theory he wanted the static universe
and he needed this extra term when he
was persuaded that the Universe was not
static but was actually expanding he
ditched his cosmological cards which was
a mistake he regarded the introduction
of this number this constant as his
biggest blunder
but the trouble is that Einstein's
blunders even turned out to be true
and this one actually something like
that turns out to be true of the
universe so you actually do have this
expanding Universe in the future which
is doing this exponential expansion now
and you can squash it down and it
squashes down rather nicely yes squash
is starting to find
a space-like boundary which means really
it's it's a time in a sense it's time
Infinity but it's like a honest time and
when you squash it down
it makes a nice smooth boundary so
you've got a nice smooth boundary
beginning which is stretched out big
bang and the nice smooth boundary in
squash down Infinity
you might think they're very different
from each other the Big Bang is very
very dense very very hot
the remote future will be very very
rarified and very very cold
but when you squash
the temperature goes up
when you stretch the temperature goes
down the density and temperature go down
at the beginning and they dig a you up
at the future and I also I really rather
like each other
you might think that this really cold
rarified remote future is completely
utterly different with a big bang where
you've got hot dense
but when you do this conformal stuff
stretch out the Big Bang squash dancing
they pretty like each other so I thought
well maybe they're not just like each
other and maybe they really are not the
same I wouldn't go that far but the big
bang
is the continuation of the remote future
of a previous Eon I'm calling it so
rather not rather than calling it our
universe which begins with the big bang
and ends at the remote future I'm saying
that's one Eon I like to spell it in the
Aeon exotic so the Big Bang
was the continuation of somebody else's
Eon prior to us our Eon in the remote
future
will be continued into the Big Bang of
this remote future it's crazy idea but
not so crazy as it doesn't make sense
mathematically and physically
and it's it's so the what what looks
like the the past the past Infinity for
us is somebody else's future Infinity so
it's cyclical in that sense
and yeah our past Big Bang was the
remote future
I used to give lectures on this thinking
nobody will ever be able to prove me
wrong and so I can go on talking about
this forever
and then I thought hey maybe there is a
way of proving
so I thought about signals which might
get through and the first idea I had
about this
was
collisions between supermassive black
holes you see we are in our galaxy is in
a cluster of galaxies
there's the Andromeda galaxy which is
actually a lot bigger than us they're a
black hole is much bigger than ours yeah
we are in a collision course with the
Andromeda galaxy in the few thousand
million years we will the things will
come together and our black holes well
they won't hit each other straight away
but they'll feed each other out a few
more thousand million years no spiral
into each other it will go up our one
down and have it for today I mean it's
not big enough but nevertheless that
will
produce a huge
gravitational wave impulse which will go
out
and okay that's we won't see much of
that we won't be around by then but
however things like that in the previous
year will produce gravitational wave
signals which we might be able to see
right
and I claim that we do see them
and these are seen the initial analysis
was done by my Armenian colleague
a lot of people complained about the way
he did it and all that and and as you
could see from the pictures there's
something going on yeah it just you
can't it's not fluke there's something
going on there some Polish colleagues
headed by Christoph Meisner did the
analysis completely differently and they
found distinct evidence that these yeah
ring structures that you would see in
the sky are actually there then I had
another idea of what I call it Hawking
points
you see this is getting back to the
black holes the black holes
sit around and sit around and sit around
and sit around
they do slightly radiate this is hawking
evaporation
they don't do that until they're hotter
than the background yeah black holes are
extremely cold
however the universe expanding expanding
expanding expanding and it gets colder
and colder and colder and ultimately
the rest of the universe gets colder
than the black hole then it starts to
radiate away it's old with entropy stuff
you were asking me before and it
radiates away and finally disappears in
a pop
now that's the ultimate fate of a
cluster of galaxies in our eon
so that'll happen to us eventually and
this black hole swallows everything else
dominates everything doesn't swallow all
the matter probably most of it though
and then it shrinks away because it
loses
its energy by Hawking evaporation
all that gets squashed through into a
teensy weensy Point into the next Eon
yeah and you get a burst of radiation
which would reach something like eight
times the diameter of a moon because you
don't see you don't see the radiation
for 380 000 years 380 000 years it's the
photons and the light of energy is
jiggled around only when 380 000 years
happens and they can stop the leak out
and by then what would have been a point
reaches what we now see is eight times
the diameter of the Moon so I claim
and we see those spots those spots are
with a confidence level of
99.98 I I don't do the statistics I rely
on my colleagues for that 99.98
percent confidence level that these
spots are actually there
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas